so let's take a look at the code to add
this new method greet by period to
application so here I'm in hello world
endpoints Java I have to find my new
function greet by period still got the
name argument and then it's got a named
period argument period and just for
variety although the name is at named
period
I'm calling the argument time of day
just to show that whatever's the app
named is what is required to be
specified in the request and all I'm
doing here is returning new hello class
name time of day hour hello class class
didn't actually have this constructor so
I added it it's pretty simple here's the
new constructor in hello class
pass the name the period construct a new
message good this would be morning let's
say good morning Lauren good morning
Lauren okay so let's see if it works I'm
gonna run it on the dev server save my
changes it's always a good thing to do
okay let's go over to localhost in the
browser and I'm gonna go straight to the
api's explorer oh goodness
got an error that never happens failed
retrieve API configs was status 500 all
right
first instinct panic second instinct go
back and check the code and you said got
the error showing up here to fail to
retrieve the API configs that means
there's something wrong with my endpoint
function so let's look at hello world
endpoints greet by period all looks good
what's the problem aha it's a copy and
paste error see here I copy and pasted
this from the previous method say hello
by name and I forgot to update the
function name so I'll just fix that real
quick
you can't have two functions exposed
with the same name actually by period
save it and actually when you make
changes in the Java code and you save it
you'll usually find that the changes get
automatically propagated out to
localhost
it says reloading the web application
file has changed so
need to run it again I'll just go
straight to localhost reload the api's
explorer okay good this time it works
now drill down into my api here's my new
one greet by period enter a name and
it's the afternoon now and then let's
look at the response there it is
good afternoon and that good afternoon
butter cup because butter cups a name I
gave so one other thing to look at is
the code for index.html and hello Jes
let's take a quick look at those
index.html really all we had to do was
add the the new input feel for period
it's called period field and the new
button for the new greeting then in
hello Jay s in enabled buttons that we
needed to enable the function for the
new button here's the new button input
greet by period we're going to call the
function greet by period we're going to
update the button label now we have to
define greet by period and here it is
it's very similar to greet by name but
we get the name field we get the value
of the name out of the HTML we get the
period out of the period field element
we construct the request and here we're
calling the greet by period function and
then we're specifying the arguments the
arguments are name and period now
because we've called the period we've
named the period argument at period this
must exactly match and then we execute
it and we call the say hello callback as
before and again it throws up an alert
dialog box showing us the message in the
response that's all there is to it